for more than a hundred thousand years
humanity has buried their dead we commit
the bodies of our deceased to the ground
earth to earth ashes to ashes
dust to dust in the hope that one day
our dearly departed might get to enjoy
some form of eternal life but eternal
life might be less appealing than it
sounds perhaps there's a reason that
humans bury their dead maybe it's so
that the dead stay buried and luckily
they do
at least most of the time accessible
only via a cargo elevator and not marked
on any official foundation blueprints
beneath the northwest corner of
overwatch command lies scp-5555
this scp isn't a creature or carnivorous
monster it's not a gateway to another
dimension or an entity with the power to
rewrite the very fabric of reality
itself
no
scp-5555 is a mass grave filled with
corpses a pit of unknown origin and
indeterminable death each body exhumed
from within scp-5555
shows various anomalous traits
these bodies can be removed from the
mass grave without any incident but
given the incalculable depth of this
vast corpse-filled pit continued
excavation of scp-5555
would likely only reveal further bodies
and fewer answers as to how they came to
be buried beneath the foundation's
overwatch command the bodies were
covered during the initial excavation of
scp-5555
vary in their physical attributes as
well as their causes of death when one
can even be determined one body appears
to be a man whose age and ethnicity are
both unclear as is how he died but his
body is perfectly preserved showing no
signs of decomposition another of the
corpses has its head covered with a
burlap sack and a noose tightened around
its neck when these are removed they
reveal an identical noose and sac
underneath when those are removed they
reveal another and on and on and on the
cause of death in this instance is at
least apparent strangulation suggesting
that the deceased was intended to suffer
before their death some of the other
bodies removed from the pit include one
belonging to a middle-aged allertique
woman whose entire skeleton is formed of
ice that doesn't melt under increased
temperatures while a different body is a
human male with 80 of its organs
surgically replaced with artificial ones
driven by gears and mechanisms that
continue to tick away long after death
an adolescent female with dark blue skin
has two severed hands grasping its
throat while a caucasian woman was found
with both of her eyes gouged out perhaps
most curious of all is the coffin
crafted from black stone that cannot be
opened all attempts to open it have been
resisted by some form of internal force
keeping the coffin shut while it's
unable to be opened it is believed to
contain a human inside a coffin with a
person inside of it those familiar with
the objects contained by the foundation
may make a connection to scp-076
able a humanoid entity also contained
inside a coffin a curious connection too
as you'll come to see when dealing with
scp-5555
the appearance of many familiar faces
may be more than just vague connections
none of these corpses or their various
anomalous properties answer any of the
pressing questions about scp-55
exact nature and origin in fact the
bodies found within the grave only raise
new questions about this seemingly
bottomless pit that the foundation was
either built over or knowingly hides
beneath its lowest depths the truth
behind
scp-5555 is shrouded in mystery
unanswered questions piled on top of
each other like the bodies in the mass
grave itself a pile that stacks all the
way up to the highest levels of the
foundation's own administration in
actuality the bodies buried in
scp-5555 are part of a vast and
insidious game played by the heads of a
number of gois or groups of interest as
well as the scp foundation's very own
administrator but how do the corpses of
these anomalous beings factor into the
aforementioned game and what is the
ultimate outcome examining the file
describing scp-5555
albeit with adequate o5 security
clearance answers some of these burning
questions about the mystery at play dr
everett mann the current 05-1 was the
first to uncover the existence of
scp-5555
and the corpses contained within it mann
created a series of notes detailing his
findings intended for his successor in
these men claimed that the administrator
won francis fritz williams the only
figure with authority above that of the
o5 council blackballed him meaning fritz
williams had voted against allowing dr
mann to remain a member of the scp
foundation everett mann had believed the
administrator to be his friend so
naturally it came as a surprise when
fritz framed him for an elaborate plot
to eliminate man's fellow overseer
council members based on the information
from his own 05-1 predecessor man
believed whoever took up the role after
he was voted out would have to take up
the role of killing fritz for the good
of the foundation but what connection
between fritz and a pit full of
anomalous corpses could possibly warrant
man's urging his successor to eliminate
the foundation's administrator dr man's
notes to his successor continued with
detailed instructions as to how they
would go about killing fritz and that
firstly they would require a lair
man himself was holed up in an isolated
arctic shack for three decades after
being blackballed by the administrator
before fritz sent his own private death
squad after the former overseer mann
stressed the importance of having a
defensible isolated location stocked
with armed guards and traps for his
successor to lie and wait for fritz it
was because of the traps man had set in
his shack that he was able to escape
fritz's death squad with his life
secondly man urges his new 05-1
successor to always have several escape
plans in place and to be prepared to
leave the lair or indeed any other
location at any time dr mann also
suggested telling falsified escape plans
to close friends in case fritz got to
them first or finding an scp that allows
the new 05-1 to teleport to safety third
man suggests the need for multiple fully
stocked safe houses after all escape
plans are entirely pointless unless
you've got somewhere secure to actually
escape to everett mann also suggested
much like his advice with escape plans
to have fake safe houses or scp
anomalies on hand to get you to the real
ones how does one obtain access to an
scp according to man placing moles or
blackmailing personnel within every
foundation facility is one way as doing
so granted him access to scp-268
a hat that makes its wear practically
invisible which came in handy during his
escape of course installing your own
trusted moles is a potentially tricky
feat to accomplish given that fritz has
the entire foundation and many other
groups of interest in his thrall but if
anyone has the power to do so and by
extension the power to bring fritz down
it would be another overseer of course
man's plot to eliminate fritz and highly
detailed words of warning to his
successor do little to explain the
pitfall of anomalous corpses contained
within the file for scp-5555
is an email to the foundation's
administrator from the ceo of
wondertainment an anomalous toy
manufacturer and one of a number of
groups of interests to the foundation in
it the ceo congratulates fritz on an
excellent win and asks for a copy of an
unknown file as well as mentioning the
leaders of other groups of interest such
as the church of the broken god
according to the email this unidentified
file was to be sent physically as
opposed to electronically giving dr mann
his next lead in uncovering the mystery
of scp-5555
mann traveled to the headquarters of
wondertainment wonderworld to retrieve
the file using his special hat to avoid
detection seems like an easy enough task
except wonder world is a pocket
dimension that slowly transforms human
beings into
something else time working against him
man hastily made his way to wonder tower
and attempted to recover the file that
would maybe give him all the answers to
this bizarre twisted mystery
unfortunately wondertainment's ceo dr
holly wondertainment got to him first
confronted by dr wondertainment everett
mann demanded to know who was involved
in the scheme besides her and the
administrator he posited that the o5
council might be somehow involved but dr
entertainment claimed that the game
being played was above and beyond their
little numbers club holly proceeded to
point a large acid-filled super soaker
at man and ordered him down onto his
knees when they asked what purpose of
the mass grave
scp-5555 was following a fight and the
apparent death of dr wondertainment man
escaped wonderworld with a file
containing an updated version of the
scp-5555 description and containment
procedures the key points featured in
this
scp-5555 document are mentions of
sealing the mass grave with concrete
after completing the turnover and
re-establishing the facade it also
mentions that any already cataloged scp
entering the pit will die with its
personality attributes and any anomalous
qualities being passed on to a new
entity which will appear close to the
location of the initial scp's discovery
so the pit can not only kill any scp
that enters it but can also instantly
recreate them with slight differences
and reposition them does this mean the
bodies in scp-5555
are those of former scps to answer that
we'll have to take another look at the
corpses let's take a look at some of
these bodies and try to make some
connections we already discussed the
similarities between the coffin and
scp-076
able the entity who also rests inside a
large black coffin next we have a corpse
dressed in yellow with a burlap sack
covering its head tightened in place
with a noose and removing it causes
another sack and another noose to appear
under it if you ask us that sounds a lot
like scp-701
the hanged king's tragedy which revolves
around a play that heralds the arrival
of a mysterious entity that calls itself
the hanged king a being with connections
to the extra-dimensional realm of
alagara the hanged king entity in
scp-701
revels in decadence and chaos so maybe
it's better for it to be thrown into
scp-5555
next we have a corpse that's been
altered with mechanical gears that
certainly sounds familiar too
scp-217 is a virus that turns the body
into a clockwork being replacing organs
and tissue with the appearance of gears
and metal foundation researchers even
notice the similarity between the body
and the appearance of a corpse fully
transformed by a cp217
but there's also the connection to dr
charles gears the famed researcher who
acts as cold as ice and frequently
researches anomalies with connections to
the mechanic religion and the church of
the broken god it's been long rumored
that gears body is also altered taking
on the appearance of clockwork there's
no telling what this connection means
but it's definitely something to think
about next in our retrospective we have
a white woman whose eyes were gouged out
while this doesn't exactly narrow
anything down the corpse's secondary
anomalous properties certainly do
photographs of the body show a pair of
blue eyes that when viewed through video
follow the camera a girl and a camera
that sounds a lot like scp-105
the photographer formerly known as iris
thompson who can manipulate the images
in the photographs she takes on her
camera iris is typically one of the
friendlier more approachable anomalies
housed by the foundation and seeing her
like this is heartbreaking so if the
corpses in the pit are former scps
themselves and existing objects are
reincarnated and modified after being
placed there how many times has this
happened over the years hidden files
display text results involving numerous
ultra famous anomalies including scp-173
which reappeared in an art exhibit
before it was contained again but
foundation researchers were shocked to
find that this time the statue was made
of concrete giving it the appearance we
all know today another test example
involved scp-049 the plague doctor who
was lured into the pit using a vial of
liquid that he was convinced contained a
vital component to his medical mission
scp-049 reappeared in france this time
wearing the familiar plague doctor mask
over his apparent previous attire a gas
mask there had been mention of some sort
of game being played by the foundation
administrator and the heads of various
groups of interests involving a number
of anomalies and the killing and
recreation of different scps many
turning into those that exist within the
scp archive after dr everett mann's
encounter with dr holly wondertainment
an email to fritz from the head of the
global occult coalition congratulated
the administrator for an exciting
addition to the game in the form of dr
mann tracking the goi's leaders some
such as the leader of the church of the
broken god contacted fritz to express
their displeasure at including the risk
of being murdered by man they claimed
that introducing such a rogue element to
the game after fritz had already won
felt like an indulgent victory lap in
addition one reported that hollywood
entertainment had proclaimed dying to be
unpleasant when she had woken up after
man had seemingly killed her in trying
to uncover the truth about this sinister
game man had found himself an unwilling
participant it appeared that the
administrator and the goi leaders were
immortal and while they could be
temporarily killed like dr
wondertainment it wasn't exactly an
enjoyable experience some goi leaders
even theorized that fritz introduced man
to their game as a way of eliminating
them or their organizations however man
had no desire to kill any of them apart
from fritz himself the leader of the
entire game in his notes man urges his
05-1 successor to share the scp-5555
file with the other members of the o5
council to spread awareness of the
danger that fritz his various
conspirators and their game poses
traveling to england man attempted to
obtain fritz's location from robert
momero high priest of the church of the
broken god however he found himself
trapped by romero and herman fuller head
of another group of interest the
anomalous circus fuller knew that man
had worked alongside fritz for years and
could prove useful for the next round of
the game while romero told him to simply
kill dr mann stating he wasn't worth
dying again however fritz appeared
shortly after to take mann into custody
threatening to kill his associates
bomero and fuller if they didn't release
man while romero appeared more afraid of
the dying process fuller refused to
relent resulting in an exchange of
gunfire fritz dragged the injured man
away patched up his wounds and left him
in a safe house with clean clothes
bathroom facilities and a note
explaining what had happened fritz's
node told man that he'd left him a plane
ticket to toronto encouraging him to
travel there and to take out the critic
head of are we cool yet one of fritz's
fellow conspirators the administrator
also left another updated version of the
scp-5555 file this time detailing not
scps that had been replaced but members
of foundation staff it also stated that
05-2
05-2-05-13 were all dead at fritz's hand
leaving only dr mann 05-1
as fritz felt like they'd bonded
reassuring the other leaders that he
wasn't acting against them fritz
explained through emails that he had
shaped man into the perfect element for
their game man departed for toronto
assaulting the critic in an effort to
gain more information while also
simultaneously carrying out fritz's
wishes dr everett mann for his part
continued to carry out fritz's dirty
work tracking the various goi leaders
and replaced foundation staff determined
to topple fritz and his game once and
for all come the start of the new game
fritz and all his associates had
switched roles with each other the
administrator of the foundation took on
the role of dr wondertainment dr
wondertainment became the prophet of
meccan a representative of the church of
the broken god the role of the global
occult coalition's d.c alphine became
jude kyrot a member of the mischievous
gamers against weed group of interest
this new iteration of the game also
assigned dr man the role of nobody his
win conditions for the game were to kill
all the others having himself been made
one of them and immortal by fritz
assembling his notes for the future o5
council man set out on his hunt for
fritz carrying with him a relentless
grudge and signing off with a single
item on a to-do list kill
fritz the story of
scp-5555 and the ongoing game that it
relates to perhaps explains why we bury
our dead sometimes uncovering them can
reveal secrets that should never see the
light of day some secrets much like the
dead are best left buried next why not
check out scp-088 the stairwell and
scp-096 the shy guy for more anomalous
tellings and explanations of the scp
foundation from scp explained